au cœur de l'estukrainien la ville
d'izum il y a quelques jours encore le
drapeau russe flottait ici
aujourd'hui la ville est désertée
char abandonnée et bâtiment ruines
témoignent du retrait précipité de
l'armée de Moscou après des mois
d'occupation
de véhicules sont arrivés
de sommes allés à leur rencontre les
larmes aux yeux nous les attendions on
ne pouvait pas imaginer qu'il viendrait
de façon aussi inattendue on les attend
depuis près de six mois on est tellement
heureux
de la reconquête de l'Ukraine et du
succès d'une offensive éclaire fin août
une première opération est lancée dans
le sud l'objectif officiel Carson mais
c'est une simple diversion car les
forces ukrainiennes sont en réalité
déployées massivement dans le nord-est
début septembre balakia puis isuz sont
libérés
depuis le début du mois de septembre nos
soldats ont déjà libéré 6000 km² de
territoire Ukrainiens dans l'Est et le
Sud et nous continuons d'avancer
au total une vingtaine de villes
ukrainiennes aurait été reconquises
seulement 24 heures